it was 50 years ago nearly for the first
jumbo jet
for the predecessor doac
and at one point the airline had the
largest fleet of jumbo jets
in the world today they're saying their
final device
to the last two remaining ones at
heathrow airport they're carried
millions of passengers throughout their
service both of these models were from
the 1990s
the last time they actually carried
passengers was in march
in april of this year before the
pandemic grounded them
most of the rooms they covered were to
the us to canada
to china and to india those are the
destinations that were really
decimated by the global downturn in
travel and you can see
this huge plane getting ready to
take off now it really is impossible to
overstate
the scale of it at one point it was the
largest aircraft
in the world you can still fit about 50
pound cars
on the wingspan we've got 200 feet of
the wings
you see the standoff that the fire truck
are giving
over here as
just tell us a little bit more though
about the jumbo itself i mean look at it
if you're into planes if you're not into
planes that is a
beautiful beautiful machine and
certainly lots of the people who worked
on it have a huge amount of affection
for it
so emotional here nile so many people
gathered
to see it fly for one last
time the pilot that's operating one of
these planes
has actually flown on it for more than
20
years and actually i mean plans were
referred to already before the pandemic
to start
replacing the jumbo jet because it's a
hugely expensive plane it's huge it
dozels a lot of fuel and there are
modern aircraft that are more
fuel efficient but that wasn't supposed
to happen until
2024 and in fact last year a number of
them were actually refurbished because
the airline expected them to keep on
running
until 2024. unfortunately the pandemic
put
an end to all of this but there's a huge
turn out here at heathrow
to see these magnificent planes fly for
one last time and if you look at the
tail height it is
equivalent to a multi-storey building
i actually walked up to it earlier on
today and it was really overwhelming to
see the size
and the scale of it it was the largest
aircraft in the world
at one point it can carry hundreds of
passengers more than 300 passengers and
you could often see lane spotters
lining up the outer perimeter of
heathrow airport
trying to catch a glimpse of the 747
as it rolls down the runway a ground
speed of 180 miles per hour
once it reaches cruising altitude it's
around
560 miles per hour and it really was one
of those iconic planes of the 20th
century that really
democratized travel it brought travel to
the masses of people
uh who could uh you know it was no
longer a luxury
uh limited to the very few and it is
really a sad day for so
many here at heathrow uh who have worked
for british airways either as engineers
or pilots or ground or crew staff
who have come to say their final
goodbyes to these
magnificent aircraft i think we can see
one of them
getting ready to take off they were
supposed to do it at the same time but
unfortunately british weather as we know
rather unpredictable so uh they will be
doing it uh
one after the other so the plan is also
for one of the planes to come back sort
of moved
over heathrow airport which is their
base
for one final goodbye before it carries
on
their final journey and it really marks
such an important date
in british aviation history really now
um
i suppose for many people the old jumbo
jet the 747 is a reminder that once upon
a time
taking a plane journey was actually a
glamorous and enjoyable thing to do
yes i mean it makes it really difficult
to sort of imagine now we are so used to
getting crammed
in small flights but uh back in the
heyday of 747s the top deck was called a
bubble it had
kind of lounges people were you know
drinking it was a rather glamorous
environment and i think it really
kept that image throughout its history
perhaps it's the most
famous uh plain in the world
it's certainly the most distinctive one
it has that
hum that you can recognize that's so
famous and
popular with flame spotters and it
really has been immortalizing
the popular culture in so many films and
in
cinema in books and i think it's really
kept a special place
in a lot of uh people's memory
i mean my first time flying long haul
was on a jumbo agenda i still remember
it and it was such a
such an extraordinary experience i've
never been on an aircraft that was
so huge and the takeoff was
pretty much uh it was so gentle you
could hardly
feel anything so it really kept in my
memory
as one of the kind of remarkable
milestones
of travel and it is really so
special to see so many people who have
worked on this aircraft
throughout the decades here at va just
turning off
uh to have such a special connection to
a plane perhaps it's funny to think
about it but it
was almost like a home for them so many
of them have worked on it
for so many decades and have come today
to say their final goodbye now
big question what happens next where do
they go after this oh in fact
time for takeoff
i know is that getting ready
for takeoff and we're all very excited
to see it finally soar in the sky but
it's a bittersweet moment
because it will never fly commercially
again the last time that these two
planes that are in heathrow are today
that are taking off the last time they
actually carried passengers
it was in march and in april it was from
the us
it was from dallas and from miami and it
was they were supposed to be in service
for a few more years a few of them got a
new
lick of paint but the pandemic that has
put such a terrible strain
on the global travel industry has put
them
to an early early demise